-We actually had a great show
last night. Jared Leto was here.
His new Marvel movie,
"Morbius"...
-Ooh.
-...is out this weekend.
I'm always blown away by how
he's able to disappear
into his roles.
[ Laughter ]
Really, it's amazing.
Actually, something amazing
last night
when Jared was here
right before the show.
-Really?
-Check this out.
[ Knocks ]
Hey, Jared!
I'm so excited you're
on the show tonight.
Just wanted to --
[ Laughter ]
Oh. Sorry.
I thought this was Jared's room.
-It is.
-What do you mean?
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
What?
-I was just in character.
-That's incredible.
You really disappear
in your roles.
I was going to say,
I just saw "Morbius"
and I barely recognized you,
at first.
-I appreciate that.
I really do.
-Hey, Jimmy.
What's going on?
-Oh, hey, Higgins.
I was just saying hi to Jared.
-Jared?
There's nobody in here with you.
-What do you mean?
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
Where'd he go?
-Right here.
-Again, unrecognizable.
I don't even understand
how you do it. It's so good!
-I'm just kidding.
It was really me.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Got you again.
-I can't believe it.
You were Jared,
pretending to be Higgins,
pretending to be Jared,
pretending to be Higgins?
-Almost.
But --But no.
I-I'm not Jared.
-Then who are you?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm Jimmy.
-Then that makes me...
-Yep.
-...Jared.
-Incredible.
-Not too bad yourself.
-Thank you.
So, wait, where is Higgins?
♪♪
-My first guest stars
in "Morbius."
[ Laughter ]
Give it up for Jared Leto!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ The Roots play funk ]
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
Let him have it.
Want to grab a bite?
-Thought you'd never ask.
[ Hiss ]
-♪ The jig is up,
the news is out ♪
♪ They finally found me ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ The renegade ♪